[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo dédiée à tort
love and thunder alors je sais que c'est
un petit peu la guerre en ce moment
concernant le film beaucoup n'ont pas
aimé il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
l'ont adoré moi je vous propose qu'on
laisse un petit peu ça de côté et que
l'on s'intéresse aux contenus qu'apporte
le film car oui malgré les avis tort
love and thunder comme chaque film du mc
hugh apporte son lot d'éléments qui ont
et auront une importance pour l'avenir
de marvel donc voilà je vous propose
qu'on voit tout ça ensemble car il ya
quand même pas mal de choses à dire
allez on y va let's go je pense que pour
commencer il serait judicieux de faire
un petit point comics par rapport au
film voir ce qui a été respectée entre
guillemets ce qui a été modifié etc etc
alors oui bien évidemment je n'ai pas
dit mais la vidéo va spoil tort love and
thunder donc voilà vous êtes prévenus
sur ce on y va gore jouée par kristen
bell est donc apparu en tant que grand
vilain du film gore c'est pour moi l'un
si ce n'est le meilleur antagonistes de
thor des comics et maintenant que le
film est sorti eh bien je trouve ça
marrant de comparer bon comme je vous
l'avais déjà expliqué dans de
précédentes vidéos gorce et la
représentation la plus classique d'un
être vivant c'est à dire qu'il vient
d'une race extraterrestre qui n'a même
pas de nom il vient d'une planète qui
n'a pas de nom non plus et c'est
justement pour souligner le fait que
gore à l'origine eh bien ces personnes
c'est juste une entité qui essayent de
survivre tant bien que mal de protéger
ses proches et de trouver l'espoir dans
les prières envers les dieux car c'est
la seule chose qu'ils puissent faire
après tout donc tout ça on retrouve plus
ou moins dans le film la planète de gore
et désertique et au style son enfant
meurt dans ses bras dus à la famine
comme dans les comics si ce n'est que la
seule différence c'est que normalement
c'est son dernier fils du nom de hagard
qui meurt dans ses bras il ya même un
détail que j'ai bien aimé dans le film
c'est que dans les comics juste avant
que son fils meurt dans ses bras gore va
le rassurer en lui disant qu'il aperçoit
une forêt où l'eau est abondante et
qu'il y a tellement de fruits
ne mourrait plus jamais de fin c'est ce
qu'il se passe dans le film quand gore
est appelé par l'épée qu'il atterrit
face aux dieux qu'il a toujours prier
ensuite il ya plus ou moins une sorte de
remaniement de l'histoire des comics il
ya une certaine réécriture et je pense
très sincèrement que ce n'est pas du
tout dû au hasard normalement gore après
la mort de son fils n'ayant désormais
plus personne va commencer à se rebeller
et perdre la foi ce qui va le conduire à
son bannissement de la tribu après avoir
erré pendant un bon moment il va être
témoin d'un combat opposant le dieu neil
et un autre dieu en armure dorée et
c'est à ce moment qu'il prend conscience
que les dieux existent et qu'ils n'ont
jamais écouté ses prières et c'est là
que c'est intéressant car normalement
gore va devenir un renégat et sa colère
va le pousser à s'allier à all blacks je
n'ai crossword l'épée du dieu noël
récemment vaincu au combat all-blacks de
nécrose world est une épée particulière
car elle est en fait consciente car
aller d'un symbiote pour celles et ceux
qui ne sont pas au courant noël est en
fait le dieu des symbiote une entité
extrêmement puissante qui a créé la race
des symbiote all blacks a été conçu pour
tuer les dieux et c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle va s'attacher à gore car
ce dernier de par sa colère envers les
dieux aura le même but que les pays on
retrouve plus ou moins la même
thématique dans le film si ce n'est que
la différence c'est que le nom all
blacks qui est le nom originaire de
l'épée symbiotique et bien n'ai jamais
prononcés pareil gore ne va pas faire
face à noël mais un autre dieu à poux
si ma mémoire est bonne concernant sont
en fait ils ont repris tous les codes
des all blacks donnés crossword mais ont
laissé de côté tout ce qui est lié plus
ou moins au concept de symbiote et c'est
important pour moi de le souligner car
je pense que beaucoup de fans maintenant
que gore et la nécrose world ont été
introduits se disent que bah maintenant
ça va être la rive et pourquoi pas du
dieu ne l' mais personnellement je ne le
crois pas du tout notamment par tout ce
que je viens de vous dire mais également
car vu que 9 et le 10 des symbiote donc
par extension le dieu de venom de
carnage bref des entités appartenant au
spyder verse et bien cela veut dire
qu'il appartient à sony est bon marvel
et sony s'aiment bien mais on n'oublie
pas qu'ils collaborent avant tout parce
que spider man je ne suis pas vraiment
sûr que marvel est envie d'avoir sony
dans les pattes dans un film thor alors
qu'il n'ya même pas spider man dedans
donc voilà vous avez compris l'idée bon
et du coup pour finir concernant gore
par rapport aux comics il y a le célèbre
plan de fall égard le béhémoth dans le
film que vous connaissez tous gore est
capable également de se créer une armée
de monstres de l'ombre comme il fait
avec all blacks et surtout son but
ultime est plus ou moins retranscrit
pour coller avec l'univers des films
dans les comics gore après avoir passé
des siècles à traquer et tuer des dieux
va vouloir lancer une bombe qui a pour
but d'anéantir les dieux à travers le
temps et l'espace c'est plus ou moins le
même délire qu'avec le souhait accordé
par eternity gore a pour objectif de
tuer tous les dieux en un seul coup bref
passons maintenant aux cas de jane
foster pareil il y à pleins d'éléments
des comics le fait que mjolnir l'appel
que le marteau la transforme en mighty
thor on retrouve le cancer comme prévu
le fait que mjolnir cache son cancer
mais l'empêchent au final de guérir au
final c'est également un élément qui la
rend digne de manier mjolnir car
effectivement tort fait le souhait que
mieux venir protège jane dans le cas où
ces dernières seraient en danger mais le
fait que malgré son cancer et son grand
risque de mourir à cause du marteau jane
souhaite à tout prix sauver le monde et
bien c'est un élément qui la rend digne
d'utiliser mjolnir tout comme steve à
l'époque d'une game où seul face à la
noce et sont armés ils étaient prêts à
mourir pour sauver l'univers ses
intentions étaient pure et c'est
pourquoi il a pu maniez mjöllnir mais la
plus grande question par rapport à jenna
c'est la scène post générique
qu'est ce que veut dire cette scène est
ce que cela veut dire que jane sera de
retour eh bien nous allons y répondre
dans le film de thor love and thunder on
nous introduit à plusieurs moments le
valhalla notamment dans la scène où thor
retrouve cif qui tombé au combat
souhaite partir et se retrouver au
valhalla également à chaque fois qu'un
dieu ou une déesse mère nous sommes
témoins que ces derniers s'évapore en
petites particules dorées jane de par
les éléments du film regroupe tout ce
qu'il faut pour atterrir au valhalla
cette dernière est devenue la mighty
thor donc la nouvelle tort lié à asgard
et tout le délire des vikings elle meurt
au combat dignement à la fin du film
face à gore comme il est normalement
prévu pour les guerriers das garde elle
s'évapore aussi en petites particules
dorées comme plusieurs entités du film
bref jane regroupe tout ce qu'il faut
pour atterrir là bas et c'est maintenant
qu'il ya débat car pour moi la scène
post générique de jane possède deux
niveaux de lecture en soit la scène peut
simplement servira à confirmer que jen a
bien atteint le valhalla après sa mort
histoire de bien montrer aux spectateurs
que grâce à ses actions dans le film
elle peut maintenant se reposer et
partir en paix on nous parle à plusieurs
reprises de ce fameux lieu dans le film
et jane qui de base était une simple
humaine uys l'atteindre permet d'amener
une conclusion à tout ça et surtout que
sa mort était quand même une belle
finalité jane malgré son cancer a
sacrifié sa vie pour vaincre gore et
sauve et or l'a ramenée gâcherait un
petit peu tout ça et pourtant comme je
vous le disais il ya matière à débat car
si on se tourne vers les comics le
valhalla n'est pas la fin de jane foster
tout comme dans le film jane va mourir
après avoir empoigné mjolnir une fois de
trop elle va sauver tort et de nombreux
à ce gardien puis va décéder dans les
bras de son bien aimé aux portes du
valhalla jay ne sera pas accueilli par
heimdall mais par odin lui même je vous
avoue que personnellement dans le cinéma
devant la scène je m'attendais à ce que
ça soit odin qui accueille jane mais bon
anthony hopkins a aujourd'hui 84 ans
voilà il est peut-être passé à autre
chose et vu que tout le long du film le
fils d'hand al intervient et bien c'est
plus raccord de faire intervenir et mme
daf bref le truc c'est que jane dans les
comics n'était pas tout à fait prête à
mourir elle est attirée par le valhalla
et le fait de se reposer pour toujours
mais dans le fond quelque chose l'en
empêche et dans la vraie vie thor
n'accepte pas la mort de jane et tentent
de la réanimer au final tort et son père
odin vont communiquer et comprendront
que jane ne souhaite pas accéder au bal
râla car pour elle son histoire n'est
pas encore finie odin va donc ramené
jane dans son corps et cette dernière va
retrouver la vie est en soi c'est ce qui
pourrait se passer à la fin de thor love
and thunder jane pourrait pourquoi pas
revenir mais je vous avoue que
personnellement de mon point de vue je
n'y crois pas trop contrairement aux
comics jen a accepté son sort elle a
véritablement accepté sa mort tout le
long du film on nous prépare à cette
finalité et c'est justement cette
finalité qui va permettre à tort de
combler le vide qu'il y a en lui et qui
va lui permettre de préparer le futur du
mc uqar par le biais de la mort de jane
tout l'amour qu'il avait en lui pour sa
bien aimée il va le transposer sur la
fille de gore réanimer qui était l'idée
de jane ramener jane c'est bafouer la
fin du film est le message qui va avec
car si elle revient bator se concentrera
de nouveau sur jane et toute la
symbolique entourant la fille de gore
réanimer sera entachée alors qu'elle
symbolise normalement la conclusion est
la suite du film pour l'avenir du mc eu
concernant l'histoire de thor alors
voilà et du coup cela va nous permettre
de rebondir sur l'avant dernier point de
la vidéo que j'aimerais traités et c'est
un point très important je dirais même
que c'est le plus important la fille de
gore du coup et eternity et bon sang il
y a des choses à dire pour être tout à
fait honnête avec vous je n'avais qu'un
seul souhait concernant le fuit mad
doctor love and thunder c'était
l'introduction d'un cosmique bing soit
l'introduction d'un être cosmique et ils
l'ont fait ils ont intégré eternity pour
ceux qui ont vu la vidéo dédiée à
dormammu vidéo que je vous conseille
d'ailleurs bien évidemment et bien
eternity vous êtes déjà un petit peu
familier eternity fait partie des plus
grands et des plus puissants être qui
composent l'univers marvel mais quand je
vous dis ça ce n'est pas genre ouais il
est plus puissant que tony stark au
captain marvel non là je vous parle
vraiment d'une dinguerie eternity c'est
l'anthropomorphisme soit la
personnification de l'univers et du
temps c'est quelque chose qui se fait
beaucoup dans l'univers global de marvel
mais chaque aspect important de ce qui
compose l'existence possède sa
projection en tant qu'entité la eternity
sans gros la personne qui incarne
l'univers voilà j'espère avoir été assez
claire et pour apporter plus de
précisions concernant cette entité vous
savez que dans la hiérarchie de
l'existence le multivers c'est quelque
chose au dessus de l'univers et bien à
la base eternity est la personnification
et la représentation du multivers et
plus particulièrement du premier et seul
univers existants mais qu'ensuite à des
péripéties avec les célestes l'univers a
commencé à se fragmenter en plusieurs
univers formant donc le multivers et
bien eternity s'est fragmentée aussi ce
qui fait que dans chaque univers dans
chaque réalité il existe un eternity et
du coup chaque eternity est en fait un
fragment d'un eternity encore plus grand
celui qui symbolise le multivers donc
voilà dans l'univers 616 celui que nous
suivons il existe un eternity et il est
apparu à l'écran d'ailleurs juste pour
votre culture pour celles et ceux qui ne
savent pas mais vu qu eternity symbolise
l'univers et le temps il possède une
soeur infiniti qui elle symbolise
l'espace est normalement les deux
entités ne forment qu'une seule et même
personne soit en gros l'espace temps et
donc l'univers en général voilà bon du
coup vous l'aurez compris amené eternity
à l'écran c'est un peu une dinguerie 1
ça promet du lourd et vous allez très
vite comprendre pourquoi là nous sommes
face à une innovation de marvel studios
la fille de gore ressuscité est adoptée
par thor dont le nom semblerait être
love c'est clairement une nouveauté et
c'est même je pense la fusion entre
plusieurs possibles entités déjà par
rapport à gore on retrouve la thématique
de son fils mort affamés et d'épuisement
dans ses bras comme au début du film
sauf que là c'est une fille et dans les
comics de thor god of thunder gore par
le biais c'est pouvoir va ressusciter sa
famille et notamment son fils à gars qui
va le trahir sauf que voilà le fils de
gore après avoir trahi son père var
disparaître et son histoire s'arrête là
concernant tort dans une réalité
alternative des comics ce dernier a une
fille du nom de torun issu de sa
relation avec cif donc nous pouvons y
voir une sorte de mélange entre
l'histoire de thor et celle de gore sauf
que cela ne s'arrête pas là puisque
eternity rentre également en compte si
dans la forme nous pouvons supposer que
love est la fusion de la fille de thor
et du fils de gore dans les comics dans
le fond l'élément principal qui
composent cet être c'est eternity comme
nous l'a démontré le film avec le reflet
dans l'eau de la jeune fille ou
l'introduction de ses pouvoirs à la fin
love est désormais une incarnation
d'eternity et là je vous avoue que nous
sommes un peu dans le flou concernant
les explications je vais tenter d'amener
ma vision des choses mais il va nous
falloir plus de contenu pour comprendre
tout ça au premier abord je me suis dit
que love de par sa renaissance grâce à
eternity pourrait symboliser l'enfant de
ce dernier dans les comics eternity a
engendré la naissance d'enfants entre
guillemets un ses enfants et vu qu
eternity symbolise l'aspect global de
l'univers eh bien ces enfants quant à
eux s'abolissent plutôt des aspects
fondamentaux de ce dernier par exemple
parmi ses enfants il y as empathie
opportunités loges ou encore entropie
pour ne citer qu'eux par le biais du
message du film de thor la veine thunder
ou gore a finalement fait le choix de
l'amour grâce homogène et bien sa fille
est le symbole de l'amour l'amour
pourrait être un aspect de l'univers on
ne va pas trop rentrer dans de la philo
mais l'une des sources de la vie c'est
l'amour les êtres vivants sont motivés
par l'amour bref tout ce que je veux
dire c'est que l'ofs dans le concept
cela pourrait être l'une des enfants
d'eternity et en vrai dans la symbolique
je pense que c'est le cas mais il ya
quand même des points qui me turlupine
un petit peu déjà qu'est ce que c'est
que cette statue d'eternity exactement
est ce que c'est le véritable eternity
ou bien est ce simplement une sorte de
fragments de l'éternité de notre univers
dans le sens
du style un trésor qu'il aurait laissé
derrière lui pour les êtres vivants il
n'y a pas de réponse à cette question
mais vu que le mc hugh cherche à
simplifier plusieurs concepts pour que
ce soit digeste pour le spectateur et
les fan lambda il se pourrait que nous
étions face au véritable eternity de
l'univers 616 ils en ont fait une sorte
de statut qui n'interagissent pas
directement afin d'éviter de
complexifier le tour et que ce soit un
petit peu trop tordu on va dire mais du
coup vu que la statue disparaît après le
voeu de gore et bien la signification
serait que love est en fait
l'incarnation d'eternity lui même et là
ça nous ouvre encore d'autres portes
dont nous n'aurons pas les réponses pour
le moment car par exemple si on se base
sur les comics eternity c'est déjà
réincarné en humain sous le nom d'adam
quad mone dans le but de mieux
comprendre l'humanité et cetera et
cetera
mais bon je pense que l'on s'éloigne un
petit peu sur ce coup là personnellement
pour conclure sur ce sujet je dirais que
dans la forme love est la fusion du fils
de gore soit hagard du fait que dans le
film love et la progéniture de gore mais
également de la fille de thor torun des
comics puisque ce dernier adopte love et
incarne donc sa fille qu'il va éduquer
et enfin par le biais de sa renaissance
avec les pouvoirs d'eternity grâce
justement à eternity et bien elle
pourrait symboliser l'une de ses enfants
comme dans les comics étant donné que
l'amour pourrait être un aspect de
l'existence et du coup dans le fond elle
serait la réincarnation d'eternity dans
l'univers 616 avec du coup bas tous ses
pouvoirs et c'est tout ce qui va avec et
par rapport à ça je vous avoue que j'ai
une belle théorie mais bon ce sera
l'objet d'une prochaine vidéo bon et du
coup on va quand même finir sur hercules
je vous avoue que je me sens un peu con
car dans le fond c'était un peu évident
et pourtant je n'y ai pas du tout pensé
qu'ils disent eux se dit forcément
hercules et hercules dans l'univers
marvel c'est un héros ultra présent il a
fait partie des avengers il a accompli
de grandes choses et nous l'introduire
en tant que menace à la fin du film
c'est plutôt intelligent car dans les
comics et recule c'est le plus en rival
de thor l'introduire en tant que menace
c'est nous guider vers une confrontation
directe entre le dieu du tonnerre et le
fils de zeus et donc commencer leurs
relations par une rivalité
et voilà je pense que l'on va s'arrêter
là je n'ai pas grand chose de plus à
dire on aurait pu creuser un petit peu
plus loin l'introduction de hercules
dans le mc eu mais bon on a pas de
véritable direction pour le moment on
sait que c'est un gentil x est un super
héros donc voilà j'ai pas grand chose à
dire de plus le concernant moi je vous
avoue ce qui m'avait le plus c'est quand
même eternity ça fait depuis des années
qu on utilise l'introduction des
cosmiques bing notamment le tribunal
vivent par exemple par le biais de
strange et strange multiverse of madness
on le voit apparaître en easter egg un
peu partout mais il n'apparaît jamais
véritablement dans l'intrigué elle a du
coup avoir eternity comme objet central
de l'intrigué bah ça fait quand même un
peu plaisir et je peux vous assurer que
l'on va en reparler bon en tout cas je
peux comprendre que certains n'ai pas
aimé le film en soi si on le prend tout
seul mais en tout cas dans l'univers
marvel est bien ce dernier comme chaque
film du mc eu apporte son lot de
nouveautés et d'éléments intéressante
qui seront réutilisées dans l'aspect
global du mc eu et voilà je peux vous
assurer qu'il ya de quoi théorisé en
tout cas si la vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir avec
un petit pouce bleus qui me soutient
beaucoup et m'encouragent n'hésitez pas
non plus à me laisser un petit
commentaire avec votre vision des choses
concernant le film aux perceptions et
cetera et puis bien évidemment n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne pour ne
pas louper les prochaines vidéos c'est
le plus important surtout que là bas il
y a de quoi théorise il ya de quoi de
parler on va revenir sur tout ça il ya
plein de choses à dire en vrai sur ce
set et argo rock que le lionheart soit
avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]